Tiffany starts us off this hour in Iowa
hi Tiffany welcome to the Dave Ramsey
show thank you for taking my call sure I
don't even know where to I don't know
where to start on this um my name I
husband I'm 35 he's 36 and he's at his
peak of income at 58 a year and we have
seven kids and we're eating it all and
groceries and mortgage so fifty percent
of our income is going to house and food
and I don't and God has blessed us to
keep us afloat somehow but our numbers
don't match up and so $400 a month
carries to the next month and so trying
to figure out how to get out of this I
just found out about you in a week and a
half ago so okay well there's obviously
two sides to this equation the income
side and the outgo side why do you feel
like he's peaked at 58 why can't he make
more uh he's the highest paid in his
company and so and the only way he can
do it is by quitting but he's also a
pastor a full-time pastor and so to take
on his own company would be next to
impossible
yeah timewise I'm sorry he's a bi
vocational pastor so he has a job in
addition to the 58 thousand or the 58
thousand is his pastoral income oh he
he's a pastor and he's a painter oh okay
oh he does both full-time gotcha and the
pastor role does position does not pay
yeah okay all right okay well a lot of
pastors are by vocational that's not
unusual in America as a matter of fact
almost 80% of them are and so that
that's not unusual thing you do have
seven kids to feed and that's a priority
over him being a pastor great okay and
he's the highest paid in his company but
he's not the highest paid in Iowa I mean
there's maybe
doing painting I don't know but you know
we have to explore the income side of
this equation it's part of the equation
there's two sides to it income and outgo
these kids are not gonna eat less
they're not they're gonna wait you have
seven kids to feed you have to feed them
right and so you're going to feed them
you're a good mom he's a good dad you're
gonna do that you know I feel sure of
that okay and so I doubt that there is
that you are majorly wasteful with your
money in some way I doubt it with that
kind of an income and that number of
kids how much is your house payment
1,100 okay that's pretty tight on a
$58,000 income you got a pretty high
house payment but you got seven kids
here we go again right so this is doable
but there I'm gonna encourage you to
work on both sides now the budget doing
a properly executed budget will help you
you will feel like you've gotten a raise
because what you're doing is you're kind
of running from desperation to
desperation from crisis to crisis and if
you back up if you pan out a little bit
and you back up and develop a game plan
for the money before the month begins
you and he together and you stick to
that game plan then you will you'll get
more efficiency out of the money and
you'll feel like you've gotten a raise
so the budget works a zero based budget
go on every dollar calm it is free and
I'll give it to you I'll give you
Financial Peace University and put you
through the whole class if y'all want to
go through it okay but every dollar is a
free budgeting app and all it does is
tell you to do this you figure out what
your income is for the coming month and
you give every one of those dollars a
name on paper on purpose not a general
feeling not a few categories that are
ish we say this is what we're going to
spend on this item period and every
single dollar of his income has to be
allocated to some category before the
month begins
before the income comes in and then when
it is you're gonna feel this efficiency
kick in you're gonna get a better use of
the money okay it's not gonna fix it's
not gonna be a magic wand it's not gonna
make this easy it's gonna make it easier
which right now as you're telling me
it's untenable you're rolling 400 over
each month so which tells me you have
you know you have a bit of a budget
already going but I want you to
fine-tune it and use the process I
outlined very very carefully there and
then the other thing is you have to have
some honest discussions about you know
we chose to have seven kids God chose to
bless us with seven kids and you know so
what are we going to do for income in
this situation that's different in a
different career and that may or may not
mean he pastors for a while doesn't
pasture for a while I don't know his
first obligation biblically is to his
household take care of your own
household are your worst an unbeliever a
scripture and so your first obligation
is to your household before it is to be
a pastor especially an unpaid pastor so
it may be that the little church sees
pastor and needs to start talking about
paying him something and that's not
greedy and that's not wrong he's
providing a service and when it has a
pastor and the pastor should be paid
don't muzzle the ox while he treads out
the grain again scripture the people
that do the work are worthy of their
hire they're worthy of their money and
so mcgann the little church may not be
able to give him anything I understand
that but he may have to make a choice
for a period of time to take care of his
seven kids until some of them are at
home they grow up and move on and then
maybe you can lighten up your budget a
little bit or maybe he changes his day
job and gets his income up those are
things you guys have to seriously
consider because what you're doing on
what you're making is you're doing a
pretty good job already you don't have a
lot of wiggle room this isn't somebody
who calls me up and they're just being
wasteful with money you don't have waste
in your budget much
but you will find the some efficiencies
if you'll start doing the budget
properly hold on and Kelly will pick up
and she's going to get you signed up for
Financial Peace University and that's
going to include every dollar and every
dollar Plus which is the budgeting
system and it all hooks to your bank
account and we're going to give it all
to you as our gift thanks for serving
the Lord the way you and he are and then
you guys have got to make some prayerful
honest decisions about your family and
about what God's calling you to do they